where is the ark
the ark is somewhere very safe
the ark is a source of unspeakable power
and it has to be researched and it will
be I assure you Dr Brody Dr Jones we
have top men working on it right now
this over here is the Intel Arc a750 and
this is one of the most requested videos
on my channel after a year later when
Intel has launched this pretty much a
year later I finally have some really
good news my friends and I've been
holding out for making this review for a
purpose but now finally I can make a
review about this and my friends there's
some good news looking for a cheap way
to license your windows check out who
Keys through the links in the video
description make sure to use the code
tn20 to get a 30 off paste the license
to the activation settings and you're
all done this license is for Windows 10
but you can upgrade it to Windows 11 for
free they also offer Microsoft Office 19
license use the same called tn20 to get
a 30 off check out who keys.com in the
video description below firstly I want
to talk about this specific card because
this is called Sparkle Intel Arc a750
Titan OC so basically basically it's a
bit of an Aussie addition which kind of
means something and kind of means
nothing at the same time but basically
there's a few different Arc cards
available now so there's the Intel
Founders Edition there's some from Acer
there's some from this sparkle by the
way this is the three friend card but
there's also a two fun card that is a
little bit cheaper and then some other
manufacturers as well so it's nice to
see different designs but why I think
this one particularly here is very
different is because this is a team a
blue card you can clearly see everything
is team blue and black you even get this
blue GPU holder unfortunately it doesn't
match quite as well with the card but it
is completely blue so from Team blue we
can see that this card has a blue cover
the PCB you can see here is blue very
interesting the power connectors they're
blue apparently Sparkle is like a brand
that has been resurrected because of
this Arc and I'm I'm quite liking this
design like it's not the that blingy
blankie and this sparkle here does light
up and the interesting thing about this
is this is temperature controlled so
when your GPU gets hotter the LED of
this slightly goes like warmer warmer
until it's red that means it's very hot
and when it cools down it goes down to
like red Amber yellow blue and then
white I love when this card looks white
it just looks amazing inside so where
does this card slot into them the Intel
Arc a750 is kind of in the 30 60 40 60
and 3050 competitor because this one
right here because we need to talk about
the pricing first this Arc a750 you can
pick up between 209 dollars right now
I'm seeing on Amazon the founders
edition of a750 is 210 maybe you can get
it for around 200 for a750 this card is
a little bit of a you know OC version
better cooler and so on so this comes
between 250 220 something like that
depending on a deal I highly recommend
checking out the latest deals in the
description below I'll leave some of the
other cards there as well the a750s so
you can pick which one you like the most
and then basically which is the best
price to save the most money but the
3050 is around 250 dollars so around
nine percent more expensive than the
a750 then the RTX 3060 is roughly around
290 dollars something like that there's
cars that are more expensive and cars
that are less but somewhere in there
right now not the MSRP but what you can
pick them up right now which is about 26
percent more expensive and then the RTX
4060 is around 35 percent more expensive
around 310 or something like that
dollars some of them more expensive some
of them you can get less as well where
some run 300 310 which is 30 to 35
percent more expensive so said that now
this card is the cheapest of the punch
right and if it performs accordingly
about 10 percent slower than the rest of
the cards it kind of just matches into
the park if it performs better than 10
percent slower then we know this is a
good card you gotta wait for the results
though so let's talk about the specs
firstly we've got RTX 4060 3060 and Arc
a770 and RTX 3050 there now even though
the arc kind of architecture of the GPU
we can't compare them because it's not
apples or apples the tmus or the tensor
cores on the Nvidia cars aren't the same
as in here Intel's got their own XE
architecture and rendering slices and
things going on but if you're looking at
the specs on take power up then some of
these specs can be compared there so
first of all the a770 is called the GPU
inside there is called
dg2-512 interestingly this is not actual
Intel's own node of the Silicon this is
they're actually using the six nanometer
tsmcs to produce these gpus so
interestingly they're not selling their
own silicon with the gpus I think this
might change but we'll see now the kudas
tmus tend to cause an articles kind of
can't be compared to each other because
they're a little bit different so if you
look at Intel archive specs for the arc
a750 then you can see they're called X
like different so just so you know but
if you're looking at there interestingly
the Cuda cores are same as RTX 3060 well
these aren't called cuda cores in here
but if you look at tech power up specs
then that's what's going on there the
memory type is gddr6 and we've got eight
gigabytes of it but Intel did something
right and didn't cap the memory bus on
this card this has got 256 bit memory
bus which means that the memory
bandwidth is 512 gigabytes
per second compared to the 272 which we
have on the RTX 4060 which is almost
half of the bandwidth of this the bus
bit is half of it because 128 256. it's
PCA Gen4 x16 slot and the TDP of the arc
a750 is 225 Watts but this card in stock
pulls around 180 Watts now you can
actually adjust it and the Intel Arc
Control Center and just shifted to 216
Watts on this one but I was testing most
of the benchmarks with just how it comes
at stock but I did do a one test in the
end which you'll see when it was you
know overclocked or whatever you want to
call it you know when the power limit is
boosted over what it comes at stock even
though it's still on the basically
manufacturer's stock setting because the
arc a750 can go up to 225 Watts if that
makes sense the 3060 and 460 see both of
them actually use less wattage the 4060
only 115 Watts maybe sometimes more with
some of the cards but they're actually
more power efficient than the a717 if
you want to check out my GPU testbench
setup then I'm going to leave that in
the description below first of all
geekbench and here I'm gonna make a
massive note that the geekbench has
changed it's not keep page 5 anymore now
it's kick bench 6. even though I had
geekbench 5 installed it didn't launch
it with this card so I wasn't able to
get a geekbench 5 of this I do have
geekbenchicks of opencl and Vulcan that
you can see the rest of the cards the
Nvidia cars are geekbench 5. so they
can't be really compared to each other
but just to kind of put it in some kind
of perspective and if you want to
compare yourselves at home you can do
that with these but because I don't have
the 30 60 and 40 60 in right now I can't
give you these specs but now the Creator
benchmarks first of all Photoshop and as
you you can see the arc a750 is
performing wait a second yeah right on
the top of the bunch here all of the
more expensive cards are slower the 4060
which this card actually shouldn't
compare with because 4060 came after
this card is actually about 10 slower
the 3060 is about five percent slower
and interestingly the 3050 performs
roughly about on par with this with
exactly the same test bench setup which
actually shows that a good GPU in
Photoshop doesn't actually give you a
ton of performance so kind of any of
these will be fine even though we see
these performance differences there
moving on to Lightroom classic there's
really no difference in there this card
is very very good for you and in fact
you might want to pick up this one
because it's got a very good display
support so it's got four video outputs
three of them at display ports and then
one of them HDMI port and they're all
HDMI 2.0 and DisplayPort 2.0 that's
super Port up to 8K resolution nothing
special but if you want an affordable
card that performs very very well then
this is good also at that point might as
well go with the A380 because it's even
more affordable but now out the big news
which is video editing performance and
this is why I have been waiting to
actually make a review of this one
because I can't call it a Creator card
if you can't really utilize the biggest
video editing software or buy users in
the world which is some of the Adobe
programs like Premiere Pro now Premiere
Pro has a beta version of Premiere Pro
24 where Hardware acceleration is
enabled on the arc gpus which means that
those media engines inside this Arc GPU
which it actually has got two it's got
two multi-codic you know engines inside
like you have on the UHD 770 so kind of
very similar media engines what you have
on the igpu but now you have them also
on the dgpu but on the dgpu
theoretically they're actually slightly
better because of higher clock speed and
blah blah blah blah but if you've got an
igpu and then this card like an Intel
13700k with this card then in theory you
actually have two plus two media engines
and the interesting thing is Intel
actually advertised when they launched
the arc that they have a special
technology that has you know encoding
with the igp plus the dgpu media engines
work together and then you know they
kind of lower down the exporting speed
for example or encoding speed the
interesting thing is right now I don't
see that working perfectly because I
don't think all of the programs utilize
this or the the software support
actually for this Hardware isn't fully
um still working because you know Nvidia
has got the Dual encoders in some of the
4080s and 1490s which means that they
can splice the frame in half and then
encode top heart and bottom half and
then put it back together now in theory
what this Hardware can do with an igpu
and D GPU that they can actually split
the frame in four let let's say a
dedicated GPU renders the upper part and
then igpu bottom part with the two media
engines and then it gets all put
together but that part will still have
to wait for that support but basically
on Premiere Pro 24 beta version if you
want to get it you can get it right now
the hardware decoding and encoding on
this is supported so those media engines
finally work the interesting thing is I
have actually benchmarked this card with
the previous version the third 23.6 and
you're saying why on Earth would you do
that well because the Benchmark actually
doesn't work with beta versions but
you'll see with the results it's
absolutely amazing still knowing that
when the 24 comes out the performance is
going to be even better so the arc a715
Premiere Pro you can see that the 3060
is five to three percent slower actually
5.5 to 3.7 percent slower in the
extended and standard overall scores the
RTX 4060 which is a much newer card is
about 3.3 percent and 7.8 percent slower
and the RTX 3050 is 16.7 and 15.9
percent slower then you can see this
card is very very impressive with the
price point now this card doesn't
compete with the likes of 40 70 40 80 40
90 or even 3080 or 3090 it's on a lower
end and the price suggests that but
looking at the performance in there it's
impressive especially if you're looking
at GPU effects where both of the Nvidia
cards the 30 60 and 4060 are kind of
performing on par slightly slower but
the 3050 that's still more expensive is
about 30 slower which means that once
the Premiere Pro 24 comes out it does
make the performance even better as you
can see some of the scores are still
slower than the Nvidia cars like the
intro frame on standard extended scores
there as well as GPU effects on the
extended score moving on to After
Effects unfortunately I didn't manage to
get the Benchmark working and I don't
think this is Intel's fault because
after effects Benchmark has always got
this is the problematic Benchmark
version but that doesn't mean that this
card doesn't work in there I'd expect
similar performance differences what you
see in Premiere Pro on the after effects
side of things but if you want really
good after effects performance this car
probably isn't the best one out of it
either so getting After Effects you'll
get at least similar performance not
better performance than the 30 60 40 60
and 3050. moving on to DaVinci Resolve
the news keep being very very good the
3060 is about three to four percent
slower in the extended and standard
overall scores GPU effects bear in mind
are about 12 slower the RTX 4060
is about three percent slower and
roughly on par on the standard overall
score interestingly the 4K media score
is better but the 3050 is about 67
slower and GPU effects 34 slower so in
DaVinci Resolve it's very very good as
you can see now the 3D performance is
somewhat where the news don't get as
good because Intel Arc isn't supported
in some of the main rendering
applications that are out there what I
mean by that is v-ray doesn't really
work octane render doesn't work either
blender it does work which will look at
the benchmarks in a moment and then
redshift but basically if you're looking
for the 3D performance of the card it's
probably still worth going with Nvidia
at this point and not even AMD rather
than this one here but looking at that
blender performance there we can see
that the a750 is actually slowest in the
bond comparing it to the 30 60 or 40 60.
3050 obviously is about 18 to 23 percent
slower than this a750 which is still
cheaper than the 3050 which actually
makes this card still kind of awesome in
blender but the 3060 and 4060 are
considerably faster there like the 3060
is about 21 to 24 faster and with the
bigger vram capacity at 12 gigabytes it
might make more sense in blender to go
with the 3060 and the 4060 is absolutely
insane about 60 to 80 faster but I'd
kind of ruled the 4060 out just because
when you actually start working with
some of the
um textures and loading the vram app
you're going to be capped by the memory
bus and it starts working worse than the
3060 because of nvidia's 30 60 and 3060
TI memory bus bandwidth kind of
bottlenecks it's not recommended whereas
this one isn't that but you remember I
mentioned that this card can be
overclocked or just slipping a slider in
there and then clicking that these
settings can be applied straight away
and when launching
um you know Windows you can move the
wattage or TDP from 180 watts to 216
Watts so I was curious how much
difference are we going to actually see
when moving that so looking at the
performance we're getting roughly about
6.5 percent in the monster scene the
junk shop scene is about one percent
slower so basically no change in there
and in classroom C we're gaining about
6.5 percent so if you're happy with the
extra performance or like the heat in
there then there is a little bit of
performance on the table now if you're
wondering if this is heating the card up
in any way then absolutely not on this
card the cooling temperatures are very
very good as you can see in some of the
torture tests it doesn't go above 70
degrees like at all it's very very safe
temperatures it's just happily sitting
there in a very happy environment and
that's pulling around 180 Watts if you
push it a bit more yeah maybe you get 75
80 degrees but my ambient is 26.4 or
something like that if you've got it
cooler the car is going to perform
obviously much cooler as well so even
sliding the slider to go a little bit
more than 180 Watts temperature wise
this card doesn't have any issues so why
is this Arc released now such a big deal
it's because when you're looking at the
hardware encoding performance this is
Now supported on the Adobe Premiere Pro
but if you were running the likes of
Intel thread repair system or something
like that even if you had an RTX 1490 in
there the 1490 doesn't support a certain
codecs like h.265 10 bit 422 which now
can Hardware decoded on this GPU and
encode it as well which is much faster
than using the software encoding or
decoding on the red Ripper Pro setups
have a look at Puget systems article on
this because they went very very
in-depth with some of the encoding and
decoding performance with the Intel Arc
I highly recommend checking that out if
you want a little bit more reading to do
but in general The Arc performs better
than the 4060 and 3050 at the same price
point and add something to your thread
repair system a card that can be only a
few hundred dollars which is quite
insane so do I recommend this product
absolutely so first of all you're not
just saving money and if you do feel
free to pick up some merch you're also
getting more performance at a lower
price point which just makes this card
absolutely amazing I mean it's really
hard to find bad things to say about
this card right now I know there's still
some performance quirks at some point
because this is the newest architecture
of gpus on the market next to AMD and
Nvidia but Intel in terms of content
creation workflow has absolutely slid
past AMD no problem there because AMD
cards they don't work as well in
Premiere Pro even though Premiere Pro
decoding just so you know the priorities
Nvidia AMD and then Intel so if you've
got an AMD I GPU an Intel D GPU in there
it's gonna start to use AMD igpu cars
like a 7800x or 7950x it uses the igpu
before it starts to use the dgpu media
engines in star in there in terms of
Hardware decoding and encoding so even
though Adobe kind of supports AMD before
Intel the Intel cards are still actually
better if you don't have an eye GPU and
even if you do a kind of disable it just
to get the media engines support in
there which is much better now feel free
to check out the a750 in the description
below I'll leave a few options for you
in there but the last thing I do want to
talk about this is which is absolutely
genius from Intel a lot of people might
be saying yeah but this is not a
competition to 40 90 40 80 you know 40
70 even and you're absolutely right and
Intel has been absolutely genius about
this now imagine if they did launch
something that is theoretically on bar
or some a little bit slower or worse of
a performance than 40 90 or 4080 but
because in it's a new architecture or
the driver's support and software
support is very very poor what will
happen is not a lot of people will adapt
to this because they're thinking at that
price point it's not worth spending
money on Intel car where I can get
absolutely solid performance from a 40
80 40 90 or 30 80 30 90 right what Intel
did was gave a very very affordable
option to everybody and said look we're
a little bit slower than the 30 60 30 40
they said 30 60 at that point because
4060 wasn't out there and we're a little
bit slower so we kind of it's better
bang for buck basically with our card
which meant that a lot of people adapted
this they've probably sold millions of
these cards and now Gathering millions
of people doing testing and working on
this and because of the millions of
users all the software developers have
to work with Intel to create the actual
support for their software Adobe blender
all of these other programs which push
the software developers to actually
adopt the the ark much better and now
for the whole year when you look at the
first driver to The Last Driver there is
an insane difference in terms of
performance because previously it kind
of wasn't competitive with Nvidia now
it's better than Nvidia and nothing has
changed it's the same card so to release
something in the more budget range to
get this Intel Arc quickly adopted into
the market into the software what a
genius move as a business owner myself
I'm thinking this is a very very clever
business move and I can't wait to see
what is the next generation of Arc like
so if you're interested in building a
Creator PC and getting the best bang for
buck check out the build guys in the
description below now knowing this video
data on this video you might want to
change the GPU in some of the lower end
budgets because this performs better
than some of the Nvidia cards now it's
time for me to start benchmarking The
Arc A7 70. I'll see you soon
[Music]